This building stands
as a sort of tombstone
for a former American giant.
You might pass this
and assume it's
the byproduct of some
failure, that it probably
deserved to be forgotten.
But dilapidated,
collapsed, and broken
doesn't mean it was a failure.
It doesn't mean it
was unimportant.
This is what is left of
the Bayshore Roundhouse
on the outskirts of
San Francisco, one
of the only remaining buildings
of the once flourishing rail
yard that was referred to as
the jewel of Southern Pacific's
Coast Division.
These walls were put
up over 100 years ago
on landfill made partially
from the debris of the 1906
earthquake that devastated
much of the Bay Area.
This is where steam locomotives
were sent for maintenance
and storage after long journeys
up and down California, where
tens of thousands of freight
trains were inspected
and sent off to their
next destination.
3,000 men and women
worked at this train yard.
For 50 years, through
two world wars,
this train yard was
full of steam and smoke
and the sounds of monstrous
engines and metal tools.
But by the end of the
1950s, steam trains
were on the way out.
They were replaced with
more efficient diesel trains
that needed less maintenance.
Trucking became the
standard for shipping,
and people traveled
by car or plane.
Over time, the
Bayshore Roundhouse
became a storage
facility and a place
where mighty old steam
engines came to retire.
Finally, on Monday,
October 25, 1982,
work stopped at the Bayshore
train yard altogether.
It became an
industrial ghost town.
Fences went up,
buildings came down,
and the train yard
became past tense.
A skeleton, a time
machine, a giant
defeated by
advancing technology,
abandoned and discarded but no
less important to our history.
Abandonment Issues is
part of Seeker Stories,
so to get all the new
videos we release, subscribe
to this YouTube channel now.
And check back soon for
more Abandonment Issues.
Thanks for watching.